mini-mall operators across the country
reported brisk traffic on Black Friday
including the nation's biggest Mall of
America in Minnesota which anticipated
nearly a quarter of a million shoppers
yesterday retailers are banking that the
shorter than usual holiday shopping
season won't lead to a dip in how much
people are going to spend Niki batiste
is here with a look at the numbers what
are you seeing Nicki good morning well
because of where Black Friday fell on
the calendar this year the official
holiday shopping season is the shortest
it's been since 2013 but the numbers
that we looked at and the places we
visited show Americans are ready to
spend between now and Christmas Day it
was a hunt for holiday discounts as
Black Friday shoppers hit the stores
major retailers like Bloomingdale's and
Macy's were decked out in their holiday
best this year consumers are expected to
dip a little more deeply into their
wallet spending an average of $1,050
that's about 41 dollars more than last
year Sarah Wilson as one of those who is
ready to drop some cash that is as a
season Black Friday bargain hunter she
hit the stores as part of a strategic
plan you can go and get all of your
holiday shopping and some household and
personal shopping done in one go and be
sure that you're getting some of the
best prices available holiday spending
totals are expected to hit a record
seven hundred fifteen billion dollars a
robust 5.2 percent increase according to
customer growth partners the strongest
growth in five years the households are
basically much more financially healthy
Craig Johnson says wage growth and low
unemployment have put more cash in
shoppers pockets people have the ability
has been but they're spinning out of
household cash flow which is a much
healthier way of spending than tapping
the home equity or tapping the credit
cards another area continuing to grow is
of course online shopping online sales
are expected to grow more than 14
percent this year to nearly one hundred
forty four billion dollars as that
sector grows Beacon brick-and-mortar
stores and malls have had to fight for
traffic
up in our next half hour I will show you
how a new mega mall may have the answer
I'll be online shopping and I can't wait
that megohm online guilty's sure Nikki
thank you we'll see you next hour